viele länder viele regeln die korona
maßnahmen in deutschland unter einen hut
bringen darum soll es bei einem
spitzentreffen im kanzleramt gehen wenn
trainer ihre macht missbrauchen eine
kommission will sexualisierte gewalt
gegen kinder im sport aufarbeiten
weltraumschrott auf dem radar fast eine
million teile gibt es ihnen sollen
satelliten jetzt auch dank deutscher
technik ausweichen können
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am dienstag
norbert lehmann ist mit von der partie
für den sport solche wunder dass so
genannte beherbergungs verbot mit all
seinen variationen von bundesland zu
bundesland es erregt die gemüter weiter
heftig und so schaut alles auf morgen
wenn sich die länder chefinnen und chefs
mit der kanzlerin treffen um auch über
diese anti corona maßnahme zu beraten
einheitlichkeit fordern die meisten
schluss mit dem wirrwarr wenn man die
menschen beim kampf gegen die pandemie
nicht verlieren wolle
patricia schäfer manche urlauber dürfen
kommen mit negativen corona test oder
sicherer heimatadresse das beherbergungs
verbot bringt viel aufwand für die
hotels und große unsicherheit bei den
reisenden bayerns ministerpräsident
söder einer der verfechter der
reisebeschränkungen räumt das
streitthema nun quasi ab das behältnis
für puhdys nicht wissen scheinen das
entscheiden ist dass wir die
infektionszahlen nach unten bekommen
dass deswegen überall dort wo
infektionen entstehen wie die konzepte
haben die gleich verständlich und
einheitlich sind
söder fordert einen ruck und meint damit
klare und einheitliche regeln in den
ländern in stuttgart äußerte sich baden
württembergs ministerpräsident
kretschmann ganz ähnlich ich werde sehr
braucht schauen morgen das ja auch zu
einheitlich möglichst einheitlichen
regelung kommen ich sagen dass die
infektions lage völlig unterschiedlich
sie genau das ist der punkt für viele
ostdeutsche ministerpräsidenten wegen
der niedrigen infektionszahlen in
sachsen anhalt will ministerpräsident
haseloff an unterschiedlichen regelungen
festhalten dass lange
müssen wir zumindestens morgen er
darüber reden wie kriegen wir die
hotspots im griff und wir können wir da
unterstützung leisten
fest steht die situation ist ernst
darauf wies der präsident der akademie
der wissenschaften leopoldina nochmals
hin
ich möchte noch mal die große bitte
formulieren wirklich im namen der
wissenschaft dass wir schaffen morgen
durch klare einheitliche regeln
verantwortlichen sie durch herbst und
winter zu bringen
der appell der wissenschaftler an die
ministerpräsidenten viel zu tun für die
runde mit der kanzlerin ja morgen also
das treffen bei der kanzlerin zum ersten
mal übrigens seit wochen wieder physisch
das spricht ja auch für die bedeutung
der zusammenkunft oder theo koll ja
absolut wenn der kanzleramtsminister von
möglicher historischer dimension spricht
dass die messlatte natürlich
entsprechend hoch gelegt und
gleichzeitig ist das persönliche
aufeinandertreffen auch ein vorbote auf
den zu erwartenden soft insbesondere
sich rund um das thema beherbergungs
verbot winfried kretschmann meinte etwas
salopp das wäre eine schwierige kiste
morgen auch deshalb die präsenz sitzung
hier im kanzleramt denn die ist
natürlich diskreter bei einer virtuellen
konferenz höheren jeweils viele
mitarbeiter zu in der folge bringt dann
auch mehr nach draußen erwartet werden
harte debatten auch deswegen gibt es
heute hier zur stunde in berlin schon
diskrete vorgespräche unter anderem
jetzt gerade im kanzleramt allen
beteiligten ist es momentan regelungs
chaos bewusst und damit auch die gefahr
schwindende akzeptanz beim bürger es
wird also morgen spannend und wichtig
vielen dank theo koll auch der blick auf
die letzten sieben tage zeigt der trend
bei den neuinfektionen geht weiter nach
oben
demnach haben sich in diesem zeitraum
täglich 4000 30 menschen neu mit dem
virus angesteckt gestern lag der wert
bei 3530 in deutschland sind demnach
rund 40.500 menschen akut infiziert
andere länder in europa registrieren
noch weit mehr corona neuansteckungen in
russland hat sie binnen 24 stunden um
mehr als 13
1800 zugenommen der höchste anstieg seit
beginn der korona epidemie im land
frankreich meldet einen anstieg um gut
8500 fälle in paris lyon und marseille
gilt bereits die höchste warnstufe
und auch in den niederlanden steigen die
zahlen dramatisch unser nachbar steht
vor einer neuen runde von
einschränkungen in dieser stunde
verkündete ministerpräsident mark rutte
wie das virus bekämpft werden soll
ina baltes berichtet die straßen und
plätze leer
normalerweise ist amsterdam hier voll
schon am morgen doch heute diese bilder
rund 850 infizierte auf 100.000
einwohner
die niederlande sind ein beispiel dafür
wie schnell die zweite welle außer
kontrolle geraten kann hat die regierung
eigentlich einen guten job gemacht aber
jetzt wirds schwierig ich meine gibt uns
doch bitte klare anweisungen
ich wurde endlich eine masken pflicht
für alle einführen
das zielt auf den ministerpräsidenten
rückte der in diesen minuten neuer
einschränkungen verkündet die maske aber
bleibt wohl weiter freiwillig jetzt zum
herbst wo sich das leben doch drinnen
verlagert sind die masken eben auch sich
die wichtige und das ist es in
deutschland derzeit besser vermittelt
worden an die bevölkerung und daher ist
die situation jetzt in deutschland oder
auch in italien wo die wissenschaftler
auch sehr gut gegen besser als in den
niederlanden heute allein sind 17 tote
zu vermelden kaum irgendwo in europa
steigen die zahlen schneller
intensivbetten in nordrhein westfalen
sind schon reserviert das
niederländische gesundheitssystem gerät
unter druck unser nachbarland braucht
eine schnelle trendwende wie die coroner
lage in europa und in deutschen kreisen
und städten aussieht können sie online
nachlesen
in der zdf- heute- app dort erfahren sie
auch wo derzeit welche regeln gelten und
was sie bei reisen beachten müssen
in die usa da ist präsident trump wieder
zurück auf großer wahlkampfbühne zum
ersten mal seit seiner erkrankung
sprachcamp in florida vor sein
anhängern ohne maske zuvor sei er
mehrfach negativ auf das virus getestet
worden so seine ärzte trump sagte er
fühle sich so stark dass er am liebsten
jeden küssen würde
morgen will er in iowa auftreten anderes
wichtiges thema in den usa die besetzung
eines top jobs am obersten gericht dem
supreme court ist eine stelle frei
trumps kandidatin ist die konservative
richterin amy coni barrot heute ist tag
zwei ihrer anhörung vor dem
justizausschuss des senats die
republikaner drücken aufs tempo wollen
dass berit noch vor der wahl bestätigt
wird
aus washington jutta sonne wald für emi
kuniberg zeichnet sich heute morgen ab
dieser tag im senat könnte anstrengend
werden die senatoren nehmen die juristin
zu entscheidenden fragen ins kreuzverhör
so will die demokratin dianne feinstein
von berit wissen wie sie zur
gesundheitsreform obamacare steht zu der
sich die bundesrichterin in der
vergangenheit kritisch geäußert hatte
mehr als zehn millionen menschen sind
abhängig von dieser krankenversicherung
daher gibt es große bedenken über ihre
ansichten dazu verriet weicht der frage
aus sie halte sich an das geschriebene
gesetz betont sie in dieser anhörung
immer wieder
ich bin der meinung dass jede frage
diesbezüglich durch das gesetz oder
durch den text des gesetzes bestimmt
werden sollte indem man einen
präzedenzfall anschaut
auch bei den großen streitfragen der
us-politik wie beim thema abtreibung
oder gleichgeschlechtliche ehe lässt
sich die konservative katholikin nicht
in die karten schauen
beim thema waffen räumte ein selbst eine
zu besetzen wenn es um einschränkung von
waffenbesitz geht weicht sie aus und
bezieht sich wieder auf einen
präzedenzfall
israel unterstützt den gedanken dass die
regierung waffen von gefährlichen
personen fernhalten kann zum beispiel
von psychisch kranken und anderen die
waffen missbrauchen können
die republikanischen senatoren dürften
zufrieden sein wie sich james
wunschkandidatin in diesem ausschuss
heute schlägt zwei tage muss sich berit
hier noch bewähren die republikaner im
senat wollen amy kunibert noch vor den
wahlen für das amt am obersten gericht
bestätigen
im streit um gasvorkommen im östlichen
mittelmeer ist bundesaußenminister maß
heute nach zypern und griechenland
aufgebrochen
bei einem treffen mit seinem türkischen
kollegen warnte maß die türkei vor
weiteren provokationen
es sei ein anker die bedingungen für
gespräche zu schaffen
nachdem sich zunächst seine entspannung
angedeutet hatte schickte die türkei
gestern erneut ein forschungsschiff in
das umstrittene gebiet zu einem ganz
anderen thema sexualisierte gewalt und
sexueller missbrauch bei kindern kommen
in nahezu allen gesellschaftsbereichen
vor auch im sport die zahlen alarmierend
200.000 kinder und jugendliche sollen im
breitensport sexualisierte gewalt erlebt
haben so das ergebnis einer studie
und experten gehen von einer hohen
dunkelziffer aus eine unabhängige
kommission versucht nun aufzuklären
opfer werden gehört henriette de
maizière berichtet geschichten die
zählen
unter diesem slogan sammelt die
unabhängige kommission zur aufarbeitung
sexuellen missbrauchs die
erlebnisberichte betroffener
es sind geschichten wie die von marie
dinkel im online interview erzählt sie
sie ist damals 13 betreibt judosport als
der trainer sie beim kampf sexuell
bedrängt konnte hatte etwa sie auch
keine kontrolle mehr
ich glaube das war so ein
schutzmechanismus der krabat versucht
sich so weit zurückzuziehen dass ich so
wenig wie möglich davon mitbekommen
missbrauch im sport ein bisher völlig
tabuisiertes thema was hat dazu
beigetragen ist es die kultur im sport
die häufig auch sexistische witze
zulässt ist es der enorme druck der
ausgeübt wird ist es die starke
orientierung an leistungsstarken
trainern die dann sehr viel macht haben
eine studie der universität ulm geht von
mehr als 200.000 fällen aus die
dunkelziffer ist hoch
da heute der sport hier fast jeden
jungen menschen erreicht jeder mal
mitglied in einem verein ist ist der
sport eigentlich das breitere fällt als
die kirchliche jugendarbeit deshalb hat
es uns nicht überrascht dass wir im
vergleich zur katholischen kirche oder
evangelischen kirche im sport fast
doppelt so viele fälle gefunden haben
sexuelle gewalt missbrauch im sport für
die betroffenen braucht es aufarbeitung
und entschädigung und der sport braucht
konzepte dass der missbrauch ein ende
findet
kurzer blick auf die inflation in
deutschland minus 0,2 prozent zum
zweiten mal in diesem jahr ist die
inflationsrate unter die null marke
gerutscht
vor allem heizöl und sprit kosteten im
september deutlich weniger als ein jahr
zuvor
auch die vorübergehend niedrigere
mehrwertsteuer dämpfte die
preisentwicklung
es war einmal so beginnen die meisten
schönen geschichten und so könnte man
auch von der frankfurter buchmesse
erzählen vor einem jahr gut besuchte
hallen und veranstaltungen 300.000
besucher kamen auf das messegelände
doch in diesem jahr wird alles anders
andrea meuser mit einzelheiten den roten
teppich hatten sie schon vor der
festhalle ausgerollt dann kamen die
neuen corona zahlen und jetzt gibt es
die buchmessen eröffnung nur vor nahezu
leeren reihen fast trotzig klingt da das
motto signale der hoffnung digital
jederzeit abrufbar weltweit zu empfangen
so ist die buchmesse in diesem jahr die
frankfurter buchmesse 2020 ist eine ganz
andere buchmesse wir haben die
sonderausgabe genannt wir haben jetzt
über 4000 anmeldungen aussteller in der
virtuellen welt aus über 100 ländern
also ich glaube damit werden wir auch
diese reichweite hinbekommen und das
heißt man kann autoren und autorinnen im
virtuellen raum treffen ihre werke
gemeinsam mit ihnen durchblättern kochen
reisen gespräche und abenteuer es gibt
alles aber eben nur digital und wer doch
die echte begegnung sucht das buch zum
anfassen den leser freund auf dem
nachbar stuhl für den gibt es ein corona
gerechtes buch fest in der stadt 80
veranstaltungen in fünf tagen leselust
zum miterleben
die bedeutung von büchern auch im
grußwort von kanadas premierminister
trikot geht es um dieses thema box
bücher geben uns hoffnung erlauben uns
zu träumen und versorgen uns mit wissen
um zu lernen und zu wachsen
in diesem jahr kann man gastland kanada
nur virtuell erleben nächstes jahr aber
gibt es kann er dann noch einmal und
dann hoffentlich wieder mit echten
menschen und richtigen büchern im
weltraum schlägt immer mehr schrott
herum und eine million teile kreisen
schon um unsere erde kleine bruchstücke
ausgediente satelliten und sogar
verlorene werkzeuge führen zu
gefährlichen kollision damit bis zu
40.000 kilometern pro stunde entwickeln
diese sogenannten orbit objekte enorme
zerstörungskraft ein neues radarsystem
aus deutschland soll diese gefährlichen
trümmer im erdnahen orbit überwachen und
davor warnen
genau dort wo sich auch der großteil
unserer aktiven satelliten befindet über
die neue technik berichtet julia
schröter koblenz heute mittag nach fünf
jahren entwicklungszeit geht geste an
den start das erste deutsche weltraum
immer wach uns radar betrieben vom
deutschen zentrum für luft und raumfahrt
entwickelt hat dass gerade das
fraunhofer institut für knapp 45
millionen euro
seine wichtigste aufgabe weltraumschrott
aufspüren möglich macht das die in der
kuppel verborgene antenne
sie ist auf drei achsen beweglich und
besteht aus 256 sender einheiten
jede ist einzeln steuerbar von hier aus
werden elektromagnetische wellen ins all
gesendet fliegt ein weltraumschrott
objekt durch das suchfeld verfolgt und
vermisst gestratz
zeitgleich wird der weltraum weiter
beobachtet gestratz voll digital sie
können quasi im millisekundenbereich den
antennen strahl also die blickrichtung
wo sich ihm gucken wollen können sie
ändern
die erfassten daten gehen ins weltraum
lagezentrum in nordrhein westfalen
das ziel einen katalog erstellen welche
objekte wo unterwegs sind
so können satelliten vor größeren
schrottteilen gewarnt und umgeleitet
werden nun unabhängig von den daten
anderer nationen
außerdem wird so verhindert dass sich
die schrott menge unkontrollierbar
vermehrt das allzu wild das würde
passieren wenn bei zusammenstößen immer
wieder neue kleine schrottteile
entstehen
das könnte für einige regionen im
erdorbit bedeuten dass diese in zukunft
nicht mehr mit vernünftigen mitteln
nutzbar sind das heißt wenn wir einen
satelliten dorthin schicken würden
müssten wir so viele ausweichmanöver
fliegen dass wir de facto die mission
des satelliten nicht mehr erfüllen
könnten
soweit soll es nicht kommen gestratz
soll helfen dass das all nicht weiter
zum schrottplatz wird ungewöhnlich hoch
hinauf müssen auch hunderte
feuerwehrleute in tansania
sie kämpfen auf dem kilimandscharo
afrikas höchstem berg gegen einen
flächenbrand auf rund 3000 metern höhe
steht eine große heide und
moorlandschaft in flammen
die ursache ist bislang unbekannt die
helfer haben schwierigkeiten weil sie
die ausrüstung mitschleppen müssen
der kilimandscharo mit seinen 5895
metern ist das wahrzeichen tansania und
nun zu dir norbert und zum nations
league spiel deutschland gegen die
schweiz heute abend heute abend in köln
das ist übrigens das 100 länderspiel von
toni kroos aber nicht der spielmacher
der nationalmannschaft steht gerade im
fokus sondern der bundestrainer joachim
löw wegen seiner reaktion auf die kritik
nach dem mageren 2 2 1-sieg am samstag
gegen die ukraine
natürlich war der satz unglücklich das
weiß auch joachim löw inzwischen erst
recht nach einem zwei erfolgreichen aber
doch eher glanzlosen auftritt in kiew
von daher stehe ich über den dingen was
kritik betrifft
zurück in deutschland muss sich der
bundestrainer dünnhäutigkeit und
arroganz vorhalten lassen
bestenfalls als ergebnis eines
missverständnisses ich benenne die dinge
so wie ich sie selber empfindet
und woran ich glaube löffeld zur em eine
gesunde hungrige und bestens
eingespielte mannschaft ins turnier
führen nur darum geht's alles andere ist
vorgeplänkel wird streichende dünnhäutig
oder arrogant das würde ich mich jetzt
nicht bezeichnen aber der wm titel ist
für die ewigkeit die sympathien seiner
kritiker muss er sich offenbar neu
verdienen
am sonntag hatte er noch für portugal in
der nations league in frankreich
gespielt morgen bei der partie gegen
schweden wird er nicht dabei sein
fußball superstar cristiano ronaldo ist
positiv auf corona getestet worden
ja und beim giro d'italia gab es acht
infektionsfälle betroffen sind auch zwei
spitzenfahrer deren teams haben deshalb
die teilnahme an der rad rundfahrt
beendet darunter die jumbo wissener
equipe mit den beiden deutschen tony
martin und christoph pfingsten daniel
altmaier hatte die tenniswelt bei den
french open durch seinen einzug ins
achtelfinale überrascht heute beim atp
turnier in köln nicht ganz so gut für
ihn
der 22 jahre alte kemptener in orangenem
shirt schied gleich in der ersten runde
aus er verlor gegen den qualifikanten
henry laaksonen aus der schweiz in einem
spannenden match knapp in drei sätzen
mit 6 2 3 6 und 6 7 und alexander zverev
ist mit seinem bruder micha im doppel
leider auch ausgeschieden spielt aber
übermorgen noch im 1 vielen dank an
arbeit viel regen und viel wind treffen
morgen den osten deutschlands worauf sie
sich einstellen sollten und wie es sonst
in deutschland aussieht dazu gleich mehr
von katja honnefer das war es von uns
danke für ihr interesse
im heute journal um 10 heute spricht man
hier das locker mit bayerns
ministerpräsidenten söder und wir sind
morgen wieder da punkt 7
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend
danke
[Musik]
meine damen und herren das tief gisela
zieht von südosteuropa heran und es
bringt viel regen netz zu rücken das
heute nach bereits in sachsen und dieser
regen zieht dann weiter über das
südliche brandenburg sachsen anhalt
thüringen bis nach hessen und morgen
tagsüber dann erreicht der regen auch
rheinland-pfalz das saarland baden
württemberg und bayern der meiste regen
kommt aber im nordstau von hartz
thüringer wald und erzgebirge runter das
können so 30 bis 60 liter pro
quadratmeter werden heute nacht sinken
die temperaturen auf 11 bis minus zwei
grad und steigen morgen über tag auf 6
bis 13 grad
eine chance auf die sonne haben sie
morgen an der nordseeküste entlang des
rheins und zwischen dem oberrhein und
dem allgäu und es gibt sehr viel wind
das wird stürmisch und es gibt sogar
schwere sturmböen hier an der ostsee so
warnt das bundesamt für seeschifffahrt
und hydrographie morgen vor einer
sturmflut an der ostsee die wasserstände
können 1,2 bis 1,4 meter höher ausfallen
als üblich in den nächsten tagen
beruhigt sich das wetter wieder ihnen
einen schönen abend